before you write any else anything else
that's new I actually want you to go
back in your book you're gonna have to
go back a few pages in fact the spot I
want you to go back to is where we did
this do you remember this one
okay all right all right so so head back
I'd love you to go back to that spot in
your books it might be six or seven
pages and you should have your own
drawings or equivalent roughly of these
okay and once you get there quick it
should just hold out your book for me I
just like to see what the page looks
like just yeah
thank you for shocking very helpful they
gets great crochet and once you get to
that page once you find it key hold it
up LaVon can you I just want to say it
fantastic looks good Thank You Leah
excellent thinking it okay it looks good
very nice Aryan I can see from back here
that's how good is all right thank you
you can put your books down now so
here's what I'd like you to do I want to
get your brain back into this mode but
for this little bit I'd want everything
out of your hands and all eyes on the
board we're gonna do a bit of an
exploration back on this idea with some
technology it's why I asked you to get
your laptop's out we'll get to that in a
second okay now do you remember in fact
I've got it right here when I gave you
these three different patterns I asked
you to do a bunch of things to them I
don't expect you to remember all those
things so that's why I've got this here
I asked you to create a table for each
of these up to what does that mean when
you see s equals six what does that
indicate for these particular things
were looking at yellow is yeah so we
added on more and more shapes that's how
we chose the letter S and then we wanted
to work out how many matchsticks rule
required to make those shapes yep now
you created those tables and I hope
they're there on the page do you see
them there yeah okay now what I've done
is I've recreated those tables I want to
show you the particular way in which
I've done it which connects it to some
of the knowledge we've learned over the
last few days since we learned this okay
so let me show you what that looks like
for me all right
in fact I'm just gonna come over here
and close the blinds so you can see a
little clearer can you all see my table
over there on the left-hand side you see
it I'm sorry it's a bit small
I made it as um what mady's big as I
could
can you see it now is that a bit clear
let me just make sure I'm on the biggest
murder I can yeah yeah all right so have
a look over here now mine is it's a
vertical table not a horizontal table
but do your numbers roughly match with
mine can you look at your table and just
compare this is the very first one okay
it's just the three triangles one after
another okay 1 & 3 2 & 6 3 & 9 etc yeah
just ringing about so this is what the
numbers look like when you put them onto
a Cartesian plane something we've
explored since then here's the next
shape or here the table that I got from
the next shape and here are the numbers
that I get from each now is anyone
colorblind in the room by the way anyone
I always have to ask mr. Johnson and mr.
Clements are both colorblind so I'm much
more conscious of like colorblindness
it's usually men and boys but anyway
that's a genetic thing you can see the
difference then all of you between the
blue and the green dots so the green
ones can you see there's 1 3 3
represents the y-coordinate there's 2
and then 6 3 and they're 9s just below
10 you get the idea
right now look in your book this is why
I should go back to that page do you
remember we gave a name to these two
kinds of patterns theorem we call them
it's--that's with an L linear right now
I made a big point about not explaining
what that meant but hopefully since then
you started to piece together because
you've heard that word why we called
them linear if I just go down here yeah
this is what I want you can see that
what makes these patterns linear is I
can join together all of the dots with
what a straight line now the phrase
straight line in mathematics is actually
redundant because when you say line in
mathematics you only mean straight
things as opposed to like if I gave you
a piece of string and it was kind of
Wiggly wavy and arc
he's a line of string in mathematics a
line has to be well straight okay so
these are linear patterns because you
can connect them with a straight line
okay now do you remember we then had
this last shape
this guy and I asked you to create your
own version right and some of you I
remember bravi being a head against the
brick wall
some of you really tried to find the
pattern for this okay and it was
difficult do you remember that you're
like how do I come up with this now I
want to show you a picture of why it was
so difficult here in red is my table of
values and the dots that you get from
that pyramid shape that you recreated
okay now have a look carefully at those
red dots can anyone tell me and there's
a bunch of plausible answers what can
you notice about those red dots Jessica
what do you see yeah it's not super
obvious but it does curve a little bit
it's not straight does anyone notice
anything else one of the things I did is
I put a lot of dots to you I put more
values in my table than I asked you guys
to do and the reason why is you can see
you start on the Green Line and then you
kind of leave the Green Line and then
you even go past the blue line do you
see that and so that kind of I did that
to make the curve a little more obvious
okay now I want to show you what the
issue here is I'm going to remove all
the blue and green stuff because this
some screen gets too busy and you can't
see what's going on so let's get rid of
the blue and the green stuff okay here's
what happens when you try to connect the
red dots with a straight line here's
what happens when you try now this is a
straight line that connects the first
two dots you see them right down the
bottom okay what's the problem it
doesn't connect any of the other dots
right just as those two and then it
misses everything else and you can try
it with other ones for example I get rid
of that one if I connect the next two
dots along you get this guy okay it
joins those two and it misses every
single other dot and I can just keep on
doing this right here's one that
connects the last two dots
it's steep enough to connect the last
two that I've graphed but it doesn't do
any of the others okay so this is why
and again I hope this is there in your
book and if it's not please put it in we
call this a non linear pattern or non
linear function is the fancy word this
is what really joins
and if I just sort of um I'm gonna make
this scale a little bit different here
hopefully this shows you the nature of
that curve it's a little more obvious
now when i zoom out if I ask you to make
twenty or thirty of these shapes you
number one you need a lot of space on
the floor for all the matchsticks and
you need a lot of matchsticks but can
you see how obvious the curve is now how
it sort of like gets steeper and steeper
and steeper okay so now yeah Louise
that's a great question does it get
steeper for like forever well one of the
great things about technology which you
know we're not asking your app yeah
that's that's a good question we'll look
at this right as I keep going and going
and going you're like okay well I'm glad
I'm glad news three didn't ask us to do
this number match six all I don't know
in this number of metrics but you can
see it just gets steeper and steeper
forever which is kind of weird and it
yeah so if you go back to do they get
steeper forever because the axes have
unlimited length if you go back to where
you did this do you member this when we
were talking about the Cartesian plane
right and what do we put on the ends of
the Cartesian plane we put arrows which
you told me indicates that they go on
forever right exactly Vishakha
this one
would I call this of line now in
mathematics because line has a specific
meaning which means straight I would not
call this a line in fact in some ways I
call it the opposite of a line which is
why we call them non linear patterns
okay and in fact that's that's the
heading I'd like you to make and I'll
write it up in a second linear and
nonlinear patterns that's a heady I'm
not gonna make Louise oh wow what a
great question okay
to give you the short answers to that it
never goes straight it does look kind of
like it's straight but that's because
our eyes have trouble telling them I'm
differences as to the other side like
what happens over here that's actually a
bit of a spoiler for the exercise you're
about to do so I will show you the
answer by the end of the lesson